hi there Steve here you know giving you
different perspectives different parts
of the house here today I'm gonna talk
about enjoyment I've said before that we
shouldn't study languages because we
think it's good for our brain we should
we should try to enjoy it and some
people say you know I've been working
hard but I don't enjoy it and stuff I
have an email today from stephen krashen
we were exchanging comments on different
things he's gonna come to at any rate we
were exchanging comments and he sent me
this article and there were a lot of
interesting things in that article of
course stephen krashen is very much in
favor of reading and and reading things
that we enjoy to get people to read to
develop the habit of reading which is
gonna benefit them and so forth and so
on and he had one interesting example
they did an experiment where they have
four groups and so each group was gonna
be confronted with a list of words and
the first group was asked to estimate
and they saw these words quite quickly
and they were to estimate how many
letters in each word the second group
was to look for the number of words that
had the letter e in it the third group
was to identify or look for the words
that they found the most pleasing and
the fourth group was to deliberately try
to memorize the words well the group
that looked for the most pleasing words
remembered them the best as well as the
people who actually had time to to try
to memorize them but the people who just
look for the pleasing words did just as
well and those that were trying to
remember the number of letters in the
word or the presence of the letter e
didn't do very well at all Pleasant
association with something is gonna help
us learn language learning yeah
sometimes you know if you don't have
content that you like if you don't have
things that you like it's it's difficult
sometimes at least in the early stages
you have to work your way through it but
but then eventually the enjoyment is
there you know today I listen to my
polish podcast dad
Robert Austin Asiata I listen to
Ukrainian podcast where they interview
the
they talked about the Yanukovych's trial
and I heard Yanukovych speaking in
Ukrainian apparently he doesn't speak up
lorry has an accent or something to me
it's all the same I can't tell the
difference
I often laugh when people are so fussy
about the accents when they're starting
to learn the language I've been at
Ukrainian for a long time I can tell I
can't really tell that you that the
Yanukovych speaks for that an accent and
then I listened to my Korean and and
again I've now got to the point where at
least the the reading of it is enjoyable
and I'm saving these phrases and I'm
enjoying these phrases and I see the
phrases and highlight it again when I
come across the same phrases later on
and and all of that is enjoyable and and
of course they have their political
crisis in Korea so you gotta find a way
to make it enjoyable but if it is
enjoyable if you can have that enjoyable
connection then you will learn better
there's no doubt and as I've said before
I can associate certain moments when I
was jogging somewhere listening to he
promised palsy in Italian or or you know
cross-country skiing through the woods
listening to you know certain Russian
novels and stuff you gotta have that
Pleasant emotional attachment to it find
ways to enjoy it and the second thing
that crash we talked about was this the
interesting fact that we learn a lot of
things incidentally and many famous
scientists say that their inspiration
comes not when they're working very hard
to try and think of something but later
on that very often things incubate so
I'm quite happy just saving my phrases I
know they're gonna incubate and
eventually somehow they're gonna come
back at me and I'll learn them
incidentally I don't make much of an
effort to deliberately learn something I
let it come in it goes off somewhere
else it'll come back it'll if I enjoy it
so enjoyment and then letting things
incubate I guess those are the two
thoughts that I wanted to share with you
today and certainly that's the approach
the approach that I take and in order to
make it enjoyable sometimes you have to
change the method change the content
you're using and don't be don't force
yourself too hard to learn anything
it'll learn on its own it'll incubate on
its own and eventually become part of
you so that's my message
and I'm still working on my Korean but
I'm reaching I'm nearing the end here
because you know I've enjoyed I've
enjoyed the three months but then I
might go on and concentrate on on
something else for a while
or at least very my Korean with more
polish and other languages or or perhaps
even attack Arabic or something who
knows no bye for now